name review welcome everybody to the
world's greatest show the area 51 raid
happened on my way to Nevada see you
there this has been something building
up for months now with millions of
people signing up but who is actually
gonna go to the area 51 raid Logan Paul
when he hears he's gonna be ok
September 20th on reddit September 20th
and Nevada prison is are all the memes
gonna go to jail so many questions
Google flight to Nevada Oh Billy see you
tomorrow
my god sending backups please funeral
companies on September 21st get it
because everyone's gonna go bye-bye
not good area 51 US Army US Marines New
Year's Air Force sans why we have Sam's
everyone furries ok white or bomb
Florida man look Jay this is what
expectations actually were when we all
show up to area 51 rate and instead of
finding hot alien girls in shrek 5 we
find boring planes and guys pointing
rivals at it we're all idiots
congratulation hey I know that guy me
escaping area 51 with a map of where
cotton-eye Joe came from and where he
went my god we need to breach area way
needs to happen well what actually
happened was one guy ran Naruto ran in
front of a news guy and I see this as an
absolute win oh my god okay it's
happening
again in slow-mo very nice and the
internet was is ecstatic that Naruto
Runner the whole internet made the whole
thing worth it the Naruto Runner
will you please listen I'm not the
Messiah here's the Messiah he did not
root to run the area 51 Naruto Runner
when browsing ready now they love me
okay so this is him he says he was here
a month ago I came here and I was
practicing my my route to running he was
the chosen one wait he actually went
there a month ago to practice that's
awesome but of course this means new
meme format sunlight prism rainbow
cheese shredder try that chase I like it
that's a good meme template main quest
whatever I'm doing so what did people
actually do besides that one person
doing that route to run well you know
this is what the expectations were I
hate to break it to you this is this is
kind of how the race worth that but I
think it's probably for the better I'm
actually glad like no one did anything
stupid this is what it looked like
clap alien cheeks save easy from the
government they are all idiots and men I
am truly proud of
I mean came and be mad at them at least
they showed up you know area 51 Stormers
area 51 because facts no matter what
happens at the RF used to one rate every
single person action showed up isn't
frequently I kinda have to agree if you
like well done although if you live in
Nevada you're not a legend you're just a
local let's get real here how we thought
the area raid was gonna go I would
actually
again absolutely why would you want to
miss that a bunch of random people in
weird costumes standing outside of
government pays that's a
once-in-a-lifetime experience it's like
Halloween but we are all just annoying
people now that's a meme I can get
behind guys instead of being mad that
the raid wasn't successful wait what do
people think it's successful would be
there was an actually alien girls with
alien [ __ ] the raid wasn't successful
we all could just meet up at area 51
every year on September 20th and
celebrate it as an internet tradition
and flex on all the boomers let's raid
beaches next year and clean them up
boomers will be even more confused okay
all right that's a mimicking get behind
the era 51 mean gets up Bing bong Bing
bong pretty good probably one of the
bigger memes this year it definitely
helped the fact that he had a deadline
because all memes are just dead after a
week nowadays but thanks to the Facebook
event it had a pretty good longevity
they had a pretty good run and yeah we
pretty good me I'm happy with it
I don't want say I'm just happy that was
a good meme for once but more
importantly listen up are you a Theo
Dorian
Alvin East or a semanas answer right now
in the comments and if you say Albinus I
think Oh cringe dude Oh what oh my god
Alvin East really not even similes all
right you don't know what I'm talking
about
listen up you see this picture you see
this image which one of them is getting
the better PP leaky leaky okay which one
is more enjoying themselves more let's
just put it that way okay if you look at
this picture who's enjoying themselves
more Alvin Theodore
or Simon the albinus philosophy seems to
be occupying the majority of Chipman
inks as a Theodore Ian and myself I must
condemn that I do not share my opinions
with such dull minded persons similes
could not comprehend
oh the durian gang smash like if you're
a Theodore e'en right freaking now you
might as well admit that you have a tiny
PB brain if you say they're you're a
novelist tiny pea pea brain object Evo
no master barmy
oops too tall oh boy yo yo Senor si si
si taco sombrero okay all right let's
get this out of the way disclaimer the
following essay does not reflect my
personal belief and is Mayor proposition
that contrasts with the norm belief when
asking the question who is getting the
best head it is important for us to
disregard the Chipmunks and Chipettes
personalities and characteristics from
the equation we do this to avoid
confounding varieties that would
otherwise make it harder to come up with
a clear answer since we are examining a
still image we can only form our
conclusion based on body language well
most interpretations of the image claim
that Toki it's theater spoilers it's
theater I'm saying it right now it is
very frustrating however because we
can't know for sure we don't know what
subjective experience is and how do we
measure it compared to others who's
enjoying them so them selves more what
would you pick tell me honestly right
now seriously know me every memes a sign
10 million dollars in cash or knowing
which chipmunk is getting the best head
that's what I thought
Theodore it's Theodore I saved you ten
million dollars you're welcome
men discussing who's getting better head
oh no here comes Albin East is doing the
Jordan look at his face filthy pipi
pooh-poohing Alvin East
I was smearing there Shh what's wrong I
mean obviously theatre is getting the
best head just look at his face
his eyes are closed he's screaming the
neurochip bug is bellowing but I have to
hand it to Alvin his eyes are rolled
back and he was gripping the sofa pure
nothing nothing okay okay wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
the president is about to say something
hello American citizens the chipmunk
that gets the best head is oh dang act
we were so close we were so freaking
close gosh darn it
I guess we will never know wait hold on
the chipmunk getting the best head is
day yet oh we were so close just you
have to go through me to know which
chipmunk gets the best hat well I guess
we will never know it's just one of the
mysteries of life what is inside area 51
we will never know which one is enjoying
their PP more we will never know I rate
the meme next mean alright this is an
older meme I'm just reviewing this so I
can get rid of it and I don't have to
see it ever again because this is a
waste of time and space change the world
my final message goodbye
[Music]
brah where do you go I did not laugh at
this garbage meme mr. stark I don't feel
so good girl
okay this meme gets a stinky poopy poop
I don't like it get rid of it I slap it
away stop posting this garbage mean oh
next mean that was all the memes we had
for this week not that much but either
were some nice ones what do you think
what's that we have bonus memes as in
plural which pip I was getting the best
PP leave a comment down below
welcome to bonus means it's almost like
boners me but instead there's memes how
do you like this one if mother Fricker's
puts a gun to my head and ask what is pi
mm decimal places tell my family I'll be
home in 25 minutes you know you will
never be this cool say it good [ __ ] I
have to signs okay
good girl hmm okay York
I prefer pure every time okay all right
how about this bonus me I know bonus
memes has been a new format that has
been very underwhelming so far just wait
for the alright how about this
let that sink in for a moment all right
next to the next one next one's gonna
get you don't work watching my come suck
begin to crawl across the floor rise my
glorious creation rise no this is better
if you have your poo sock this is me
when I watch my poo sock this is so
relatable this is like lovely pause
level I could sow relate that
how-how-how leave a comment down below
how that's what I taught thought okay
how about this one gold in real life
goal in Minecraft Japan is highly
cultured society the racism in ik is
exaggerated also cheap it's it's Nicki
whiskey
by the way it's what this is a really
good whiskey and one of my favorite it's
very its hind alcohol but it's got a
strong flavor that makes up for it nikka
whiskey from the barrel is the original
French government has head hey this is
me peasants chop chop chop chop
jerk jerk minecraft celebrating 10 years
Wow age of consent Sweden 15 when would
I freak a girl in Minecraft when to make
me Hank
I'm too pissed to continue I'm sorry
gamers check out March if you want to
look epic and I see gamers next time
smash like subscribe 200 million
bye bye row finger I like how I did a
lot of push down there that's pretty
epic well you haven't tried to brew
simulator City after 50 million outros
much don't just don't it's still
relevant just down a bit